approach open your arms up wide like a
proud eagle and then tilt your head in
whichever direction you feel comfortable
slightly raise your arm in the direction
of your tilted head this will indicate
your intention to your partner and
prevent any head-to-head collisions
finally glide in slowly and confidently
this squeeze maintaining your body in a
semi rigid manner will indicate to your
friend that you are in control of the
race make sure your arms are not like
wet noodles but rather like the warm
branches of a firm oath turn your head
out at this point and stare into the
horizon turning your head inwards can
indicate sexual interest only do this if
this is your given intention the past
the past is the staple of any good man
hug this will delineate this cloth or
just a regular hug now is your time to
shine but your own creative spin on the
Pat do you like to use a fist or an
open-handed karate chop whatever the
gesture make sure it is firm confident
and filled with spirit the break the
duration of the hug should be felt out
situationally and the break should be
done as confidently as you made your
approach if you limp away at this moment
then all of your hard work will be lost
the handshake to hug engage your friend
with your dominant hand and deliver a
firm handshake pull your friend close
and swing your elbow behind you open
your opposite hand and then proceed
through the previous steps make sure to
keep the handshake throughout the hug
duration